>>Daniel Goleman: I know I've
said that children, to learn,
need sustained, focused
attention, but there are limits
to how long any brain can
sustain optimal attention.
And I think the school day should
be aware of this so that it's paced,
so that children's brains
have a chance to recover
for the next period of learning.
And what's happening is that
glucose, the brain's energy,
gets used up, gets depleted.
This is why recess is so important.
This is why downtime is so important.
We all need a period when
we do restore, for example,
one thing that restores the brain, it
turns out, is focusing on the breath.
It's a neutral thing, doesn't
take a lot of mental effort,
keeps us focused, but it's also
a time when the brain is resting.
Going for walk, playing, all
of these activities are a part
of the human repertoire
for a good reason.
They actually are helping the
brain restore itself, so teachers,
and educators generally, I
think, would do well to be aware
of how the brain needs to pace
itself and how important it is
to schedule regular periods
of rest throughout the day.
And it's not just kids that need
it, it's teachers and parents, too.